watch porn cooking shows and Blake
Shelton is sharing some pretty intimate
details about his relationship with Gwen
Stefani during an appearance on The
Ellen DeGeneres Show the country singer
played a round of five second rule--
where he revealed three things he and
his girlfriend do after she puts her
kids to bed watch porn cooking shows and
Blake and Sandra Bullock who was also a
guest on the show went back and forth
with a talk show host naming three
things in under five seconds that's when
Blake delivered this Jem main three
things
Gwen makes fun of you for my hair my
socks and the same shirt I wear every
day
Gwen cheers three kids with ex-husband
Gavin Rossdale and it seems like Blake
has nothing but love for his leading
lady and her boys in fact he's taken
them on plenty of adventures since the
two first started dating three years ago
Blake just joked with et about the
presents he plans to give his girlfriend
for Christmas like what are you getting
your special lady for Christmas can you
give us a hint a hint a big plan a big
surprise you know I like you but not to
tell you that but I would like to point
out that Kelly is so rich she is
bringing in a snow machine to Encino
California for two weeks just so that
our kids have snow welcome to me Merry
Christmas everybody
[Applause]
okay so not the most extravagant gift
but one thing's for sure
Gwen and Blake's love is going strong
the pop star recently shared this
throwback video to Instagram that was
filmed when he lost season 12 of The
Voice back in 2017 loser
I don't think you're a winner yes I take
it back I feel like a winner Blake lost
season 15 of The Voice this week when
Kelly Clarkson's contestant Chevelle
Shepherd took home the title chevelles
win marks the American Idol champs
second victory in a row after team
Kelly's brain cartelli was crowned to
the season 14 winner in may kelly rubbed
the big win in Blake's face backstage
noting that she won with a country
artist
Blake's usual forte I obviously believed
in there since the blinds but it's so
hard to one get country people on your
team if you're not Blake Shelton
no one's ever beat him with a country
artist
[Laughter]
I don't even know it's airing that but
Kelly wasn't the only one throwing down
shade Blake was quick to call out his
buddy Adam Levine whose team didn't make
it to the finale we got we got Jenn we
got Blake we got Kelly no Adam how do we
everyone's rubbing it in it's so bad and
like badass it's awesome that's what it
is team you know everybody wants to make
it to the end so that does dog like I
feel like you're not gonna be as nice
about well you know it is rough freeze
team but they did choose him as their
coach and you know he's a loser
[Music]